唉，你知道嗎？最近看到一個挪威的新創公司，叫做 Birdsview，他們做的事情真的讓我覺得，傳統產業好像也沒那麼傳統了。
嗯？怎麼說？像營造業、土木工程這種，我聽起來就很「硬」，很難有什麼新花樣吧？該不會又是什麼數位轉型、AI 應用這種老生常談？
不，這次不一樣。他們把醫療領域的「MRI」概念，直接搬到混凝土檢查上。你可能沒想到吧，掃描人體的那套，現在可以用來檢查橋梁、建築物這種基礎設施。
等等，MRI？人體掃描？這…這出乎意料了點。這要怎麼做到？意思是他們有機器可以像醫院那樣，把水泥結構送進去掃嗎？這聽起來就不切實際啊。
不是把整個結構送進去，他們是用一種結合感測器和專利演算法的技術。簡單來說，他們用「探地雷達」（Ground Penetrating Radar, GPR）來發射雷達脈衝，然後透過他們的軟體，把這些雷達數據自動分析成詳細的 3D 模型。
喔，GPR 我聽過，這技術本身不新啊。我看很多工程顧問公司也有在用。問題是，GPR 的數據很難解讀吧？需要很專業的人才能分析，而且很花時間。
這就是 Birdsview 的創新點了。他們說他們的技術解決了這個痛點，讓資料解讀自動化。透過 AI 驅動的分析，任何人都能快速看到混凝土內部的狀況，不需要鑽孔或破壞結構。
任何人都能用？這有點誇張了吧。如果數據判讀真的這麼簡單，那還要專業技師幹嘛？這會不會是他們的行銷話術？
他們原文有提到，過去 GPR 的限制就在於需要專業知識來解讀原始數據和複雜圖表，但他們的演算法會自動處理和分析，連材料分類和異常影響評估都自動化。Olav Skogen，他們的執行長，也說這是他們解決產業問題的關鍵。
好吧，如果真的能做到這樣，那確實降低了門檻。但成本呢？這種高科技診斷模式，費用會不會比傳統檢查方式高很多？
他們強調的是「預防性維護」。傳統做法常常是等到結構出現問題才修，通常都是大工程，費用驚人。Birdsview 這種方式，可以在問題初期就發現並處理，降低風險、減少成本、提高效率，也更環保。
這樣聽起來，對營造或土木工程公司來說，確實有吸引力。那對於我們這些一般中小企業主來說，能學到什麼？我的店面又不需要檢查混凝土。
其實我想到的是「跨領域借鑑」這個概念。Birdsview 把醫療的 MRI 應用到營造業，這是非常出乎意料的。我們做生意，是不是也可以跳脫本行，去看看其他產業是怎麼解決問題的？
嗯，有點道理。就是說，不要只專注在自己的領域，也要多看看外面世界的解方。那對一般上班族來說呢？這東西聽起來還是離我很遠。
我猜啦，這個概念其實也可以應用在工作或生活上。比如，我們在做專案或規劃的時候，是不是也常常等到問題發生才去解決？如果能像 Birdsview 這樣，提早「診斷」出潛在問題，是不是能避免很多後續的麻煩？
你是說，把「預防性維護」的心態帶入日常工作？像是定期檢視自己的工作流程，找出效率低下的環節，而不是等到主管催了才去補救？
對，就是這個意思。甚至是對自己的健康管理，也可以套用。與其等到身體出狀況才去看醫生，不如平時就多注意，做一些預防。Birdsview 已經募到了 370 萬歐元，而且在推出幾週後，就有八個國家的客戶採用了。這說明他們確實解決了產業的真實痛點。
有這麼多投資者支持，而且已經有客戶了，看來這模式確實有搞頭。畢竟基礎設施的維護是個龐大的市場。
沒錯。我想這案例好像也提醒了我們，有時候答案不在現有的框架裡，而在於我們能不能從看似不相關的領域，找到新的視角和解決方案。